Bangladesh's garment industry is
second-largest clothing exporter in the
world after China it accounts for 80
percent of the country's total exports
and it's expected to benefit the most
from the fallout of the us-china trade
war US retailers are placing more orders
with Bangladesh to offset increasing
tariffs on Chinese goods because of the
fact that there is no a trade war bars
in USA because of the price advantage
they are looking at this region and
Bangladesh is certainly one of the
beneficiaries of those orders coming in
to avoid the effects of the trade war
Chinese factories are relocating to
elsewhere in Asia Bangladesh is low wage
gives it a competitive edge in this
labor-intensive industry
Bangladesh has the most sustainable
supply chain currently and we are the
most compliant therefore there is no
reason for Bangladesh not to gain from
this from this opportunity but we would
need the help
because consistently Bangladesh has
suffered a decline in prices so we seek
the cooperation and empathy of the rest
of the world apparel export has boomed
in recent years but workers are not
satisfied with the new minimum wage set
by the government last year president
Trump's trade war with China is turning
out to be a blessing for bangladesh's
garment industry which has benefited
from a rising demand for its good corona
in recent study 91% of the workers said
their income is not enough to fit
themselves and their families there has
been criticism from the workers union
and NGOs that the rise in export
benefitted only the factory owners and
international buyers not the workers
Gulabi / bean a garment worker lives
with her family in a small one-room
quarter she struggles with our monthly
expenses without our husband's income it
would be hard for the family to get by
it's still very difficult for us I have
to spend a considerable amount for my
children's school fees and other
expenses like medicine food rent and so
although the country's garment export to
the US market grew in recent months
things may not remain so rosy if
president Trump's goes ahead with his
plan and impose additional tariffs on
apparel imports Bangladesh already plays
15.3% duties to the US amongst the
highest of any nation sandwich Audrey
al-jazeera
Eshoo Leah Bangladesh